and strikingly you also do business with the VVD
yes you can
so yes,
they are exceptional cases
but we send you
in Amersfoort,
for example,
also with the CDA
yes we just showed you are no longer a newcomer
you are actually 1 party that has been around for a long time
grows steadily
and if 1 batch grows steadily
then of course always comes the
Do you want to co-drive
I find it 1 interesting point to be with you
by speaking exactly where you stand
but we thought
let's also look in practice
what is happening so far
because you participate in 1 number of municipalities arjan
because it has been 1 struggle for this party for years
should they indeed participate or should they
remain honest
stick to their own point of view and above all
keep shouting from the opposition
so they do participate
in 6 municipalities in the Netherlands
they are in college
of mayors and aldermen
and if we then
who gonna call party divisions
then we actually get very good news
we do get something done
I go through 1 pair
in the municipality of Arnhem
The Hague Amersfoort and Almere,
sport fishing is prohibited
there is for the party in Groningen
1 councilor for protein transmission
that concerns more vegetable products
in food
hunting is prohibited in Almere
eating in canteens
becomes vegetarian in the municipality where they participate
and the party
also has the dog tax in The Hague,
for example
it has been abolished before
also important for the party
they have for example
in Almere 1 very large construction project stopped
because it would affect nature too much
we did indeed call all those departments and those
that participation is actually not so bad
we will achieve what they say
it has not yet become difficult in the past period
but actually they say in those 6 municipalities
where the party for the animals participates
finally 1 time
is actually going quite well
yes interesting
is going very well
yes yes and so we have done extensive research
looked everywhere
well how that goes and then we will be told
the party for the animals
has negotiated sharply
especially on points of principle they bring in something
but on other topics the local
fractions walk 1 bit
in 1 of the cities the party could
also supply the alderman for culture,
for example
but there was no interest in that
that fits 1 bit
well the way you say too
that's how we should do it in the municipality
So
choose your points and leave it on other things
I think it is especially late
see that we are driving for the first time
and I am very proud of all those group chairmen
those fractions that
who have chosen to do so
and brought in really important things
in Amersfoort
for example we have the Cap of 2500 trees
managed to stop
it was just said in Almere
yes 1 construction project
that sounds like times of housing shortage
you shouldn't have built
but it would only be villa
at the expense of 1 Forest
so the party for animals mainly has
on that necessary change of course of
really protect nature
greener more sustainable
in 1 number of municipalities
now decided to negotiate
then, for example,
you show such a culture portfolio
well that then well it is especially
we participate for the first time
and I think it's very good to
to see that 1 number of fractions saw that
here is really room for 1 green chord
to go for that
and we gain experience with this
culture
is also very important for the party for the animals
what the trade-off has been in this situation
maybe they didn't have someone available
we are still growing
and we are now participating for the first time
and I think it is going very well everywhere
and so we come
up for very fundamental
values that you will not find otherwise in 1 lecture agreement
I find it striking
you also do business with the VVD
Which
so yes
they are exceptional cases but they send
in Amersfoort,
for example,
also with the CDA
yes yes and they sometimes have to get used to us
but it is still 1 very green chord
yes and the question is natural
it is not for nothing that we start in practice where the
Small let's say happens locally
but the question is natural
this must also be done nationally
and we invited someone to someone who
comes from your supporters and that is josé duindam
and you have 1 question about co-management to Esther ouwehand
yes that's right hello with Esther
I do indeed want to know about co-driving
because I think that is very necessary
but I read in the media
I hear you say
we want to co-manage that as a party
but we don't want to add water to the wine
when it comes to nature and climate goals
and I get that
because I would prefer not to
I mean
that's why I vote for the animals
I think it's super important
I think the most important thing is actually now
but at the same time
you also put yourself offside
because we live in 1 coalition country
where you should always add water to the wine
if you want to work together in 1 coalition
so I was wondering
you just said about the party of
it doesn't have to be perfect all at once
it does not have to be perfect here in one go
we can still think in intermediate steps
and set intermediate goals
with that beautiful end goal in mind
but participate
because it is too important now
to do nothing
yes of course it is super important
and I'm glad you said that too
that you are therefore at the party for the animals
votes to really fight for nature
and climate and animals
and what I also find important is that
this is about appointments
that were made years ago
and that are not fulfilled
so I think it is very important
for example the decline of nature
you can say again
we will not do that in 2030
the nitrogen targets only reach 2035
but it is shifting over and over again while nature
deteriorates and warn forest rangers
that nature reserves are simply irreparable
I mean
that is again 1 argument for not being able to participate no
I'm not saying we're not going to participate
I SAY it is very important that the right one
party for the animals
reminds the other political parties
listen
of course we have those goals for a reason
but of course the goals of the party
for the animals
this is of course 1 very specific
question from 1 voter of u just saying
I am voting for you correctly
for those goals that everyone knows and becomes here
endorsed
but the question is true
of course very much like to have an answer
where are you actually
if we ask the question
do you also want to participate nationally
yes but the question is broader
I try to sketch that
because giving up is not an option
so of course we have to make the most of it
to ensure that the climate crisis is stopped
that we do whatever it takes to get within that one and a half
degree to stay
so the party
for the animals the pressure increases as much as possible
especially in 1 country in which you have to work together
compromise is part of it
and theverantwoordelijkheid it
1 every justvolksvertegenwoordiger
must also have
is that you protect and respect the rule of law
and that you don't say
it has become 1 bit difficult
so we let that go
theverantwoordelijkheid is also
that people trust politics
do not lose
and that is this climate promise
every time
are pushed forward and not achieved
then you also need 1 party
he keeps saying ho for a moment
but this is the most vulnerable thing we have
but where us you exist that in the opposition
say wait
ho is even or say you
I am going to participate because that is the question
and stronger I mean
the party is currently
so big that it is also quite 1 role of significance
could play a role in coalition formation
so when we say of
we necessarily want to
stick to our ideals
and do not add water to the wine
and then do not participate
because we think our ideals are too important
that means you might
1 legal cabinet makes possible
where you occasionally have 1 private member's bill
or 1 green motion
but I prefer
I prefer that we have 1 bit
of those goals just 1
left cabinet
1 dark green color
because it is precisely because it is so important now
but it is still
no November 22
so we are still in the middle of De Buurt
you don't want to say it
no I especially want
that we
do what the Party for the Animals is established for
and we were founded because of politics
are beautiful promises and
nice words
about animals about nature
about climate
did not comply and someone has to say
to here and no further
if you want to join and you say so
then you have thought about who could do that
yes you say it
but look crucial
for that change of course
and there we have the past
of course also seen a lot of it for years
you have the courage to reform that agriculture
and that means
dare to choose 1 end to the v industry
what I see is that green left party of labor
that dares
I see that D66 dares to do that
I see that
oh at 1 it is not on it
well I would like to join 1
yes it does not participate in this broadcast
no okay
so then they are not allowed in this absolute part
may be there yes
in our minds we add it
volt and the sp
volt and sp it will be 1 big club
all together
but you start
to slowly come to De Buurt from 1 coalition
that's how it is
look Pieter omtzigt has in the room
there is no room for hutch animals in creation
and I am talking about the bio industry
his voting behavior is 1verkiezingsprogramma
I'm not quite sure what he's going to do yet
so i would say put it in half
but this may be the party leading this coalition
will have to help the majority
I would say not quite in the box
because he still has to
no he can go up a little more
yes more
if so it is